this video is sponsored by bookwalker
new season new year new decade and
looking over the seasonal chart i can
already see change in the horizon that's
right unless we're counting virtual mmos
there is actually no new original isekai
this time so that's why we can start off
2020 with the only isekai sequel airing
right now that's right everyone give it
up to naofumi and the shield hero cast
carrying on the east kai torch as they
join isakai quartet 2. no we are not
doing this anymore this is a new year we
don't need to keep pointing out how many
easter guys there are alright everyone
[ __ ] gets it also easter kai quarter
two
two who the [ __ ] thought of this name do
you even know what quartet means it's an
ensemble of four
four
how many new series do we have now five
oh man if only there was a word for an
ensemble of five oh wait there is
i wish i owned a dictionary and knew
what the word quintet meant it's not
like we have five series in the isekai
quartet now so yeah
great job keep doing what you're doing
welcome to the quartet dude go [ __ ]
yourself
[Music]
let's open up to one of the most
interesting concepts this season a guy
wakes up to a broken world with no
knowledge of who he is or where he came
from he walks around and finds a dead
body who he somehow recognizes and
instinctively knows he must solve the
murder as we have presented more
information we find out this world has
been constructed from the subconscious
mind of a murderer and by watching this
detective piece together the twisted
logic of this world it gives real-time
information on the location and identity
of the killer that the police can use
this is a detective mystery that seems
like a mix between psychopaths persona
and minority reports it almost feels
like a long-lost generabuchi show of the
2010s and i'm looking forward to seeing
how they explore this premise because
it's just refreshing to see new and
original ideas in anime the kanji for
ido can also mean other and earth
put those together and
you get otherworld
don't
do this
to me
again
[Music]
looks like we have another death game
anime this time revolving around a
mobile game that gives you special
abilities gaining unwilling participants
to anyone foolish enough to open the app
if you've seen any death game shows this
one basically follows that mirai nikki
formula to the team except this one has
a yandere love interest who doesn't have
pink hair wait a minute is that legal
it's edgy and stupid but it's the
entertaining kind of edgy and stupid
where if you can just turn your brain
off you can have fun with all the stupid
things happening on screen
yeah this is probably going to be my
trash show of the season all right do
the usual quick rundown of the sequels
available the boys are back in town
because it's high q season 4 and i'm
pretty hyped railgun's back madoka has a
spin-off series based on the mobile game
that came out i don't know too much
about the game this time so i don't have
much to say except look it's baby cubey
oh
what a cute baby
right mapper 2019
mapper 2020.
mapper2021
here
[Music]
this is my first time hearing of dodo
hair dodo so i had absolutely no idea
what i was getting myself into and then
i watched the lizard guy swallow
someone's head to see if a man living
inside the lizard's mouth would
recognize the face before dicing him up
into little pieces and i was like
alright
i have absolutely no idea what i'm
getting myself into but this is one that
certainly stands out from the rest of
the shows this season the dystopian
gritty world instantly caught my
attention along with how unflinchingly
vicious it is yeah it's not exactly
studio orange level 3d but it's
certainly not enough to put me off hell
it's easier to stomach than how damn
brutal can get sometimes so you have
been warned
[Music]
there you go have you heard of this game
called great shadow legends
it's a turn-based mmorpg
this show is bad like i'd like to think
we've grown past the point where main
character straight up groping a girl
should be seen as a charming trait
because he's a cool looking protagonist
but i also don't know how i'm supposed
to feel sorry for a girl he's just so
annoyingly stupid enough to fall for the
anime equivalent of hey kid want to come
into my van for some free candy i see
nothing wrong in that
this isn't free candy and it's a shame
because you know what this actually has
a semi-interesting concept in world with
some of the most unlikable characters
you can think of so is that enough for
me to stick with it have you heard of
this game called great shadow legend
with over 200 000 reviews it's almost
got 5 stars
it's just been nominated for google
play's best of 2019.
probably not pop quiz tell me what these
three things have in common watching a
man dedicate years of his life to beat a
world record of an arcade game nobody
plays anymore and that's a physicist
talking about origami keep your hands
off azokin and this guy who can pounce
mochi at an unreasonably fast pace
that's right
seeing passionate people do the things
they love passionately is just an
absolute joy to watch keep your hands of
izokun is the latest project from misaki
yuasa of devilman crybaby ping pong the
animation and a whole load of other
great [ __ ] this one follows the story of
a bunch of animation nerds who form a
club to make anime and the entire
process around that before you write
this off as something that wouldn't
interest you at least give the first
episode a watch because the scene that
sold me was in episode 1 where a pair of
them are just going over some rough
concept art and they come across this
basic sketch of some ship what starts
off as a throwaway sketch takes you on
this entire journey as they start adding
detail discussing how it would operate
what setting you would inhabit the
sounds it would make a whole world is
invented around this single concept and
before you know it you are sucked into
this wondrous world of imagination with
them what i said earlier about watching
passionate people goes for the actual
characters and yuasa himself with this
show there's a magic in watching people
do the things they love i've been
utterly enthralled by video subjects i
couldn't care less about because the
people presenting it engrossed you in
their world and you for a brief period
can understand why they love the things
they love i feel that with this show you
can have no interest in how anime is
made but it's presented to you in such a
wondrous feverant passion that you can't
help but be infected by it this was
immediately a contender for anime of the
season and once again shows that yuasa
is just really good at what he does
speaking of shows about following your
passion smile down the runway is [ __ ]
lit and not enough people are watching
it i admit when i saw this premise with
some pretty average looking production
values i thought it wasn't going to be
my thing but now i am absolutely
addicted to this show it's an anime
about fashion design and modeling but
it's done in the style of a shonen
sports anime and if the sports anime
formula has taught me anything is that
it can take a subject i have absolutely
no interest in and make me completely
invested in it you've got an underdog
story you've got training arcs you've
even got slight power scaling showing
off in the form of instagram followers
which just made me think man if this
formula works for anything what would it
be like if we had a battle anime where
the power system itself was just clout
this pressure
i've never sensed anything like it
before hey
what does the social blade say about his
clout level it's over 9 million
followers
what 9 million impossible i've never
even seen him before
[Laughter]
you fools i haven't even done a face
reveal yet this is my toughest opponent
yet
i'm gonna have to use the forbidden
technique
this technique
it can't be this video is sponsored he
wouldn't
by rap bookwalker hey did you know that
bookworker is the official catacower
e-book store for all catacower titles
and beyond you can even find the source
material for a lot of the shows airing
this season
including inspector smile down the
runway and yes even into species
reviewers
please for the love of god can you stop
kicking me now
if you're a new user you can also use
coupon code giggup for five dollars off
oh my god i didn't know that yeah i've
never said that before yeah you've never
said that before so get on down to
bookwalker and you can raid
a new manga and light novel today
all right back to the video we've got
our fair share of the supernatural this
season first toilets found hanukkokun is
about a toilet spirit who helps solves a
little girl's problem i've heard good
things about the manga and after
watching the first episode
seems pretty cute then there's also
inspector which is another mystery
detective type show around supernatural
apparitions there was something that
drew me to this immediately it is the
instant chemistry between the two main
leads there was just something
mesmerizing about their dialogue in the
show it sits in this weird limbo area
where you know no one in real life
actually interacts like this but it's so
punchy and unique that it draws you in
and entertains you and it's ironic
because i found it more interesting when
they were just bullshitting about
absolutely nothing then talking about
actual plot points if you're looking for
something sweet and wholesome this
season then i highly recommend somali
and the forest spirit i put this in the
anime category of japan going hey you
see this isn't this cute this is baby
baby is nice baby is cute baby give you
love baby give you life who doesn't want
baby i want baby please make baby he
details a gollum he finds a lost human
child in a fantasy world where humans
are an endangered species and goes on a
journey to help the kid find their
parents it's simple yet just really well
done and seeing an anime like this
reminds you what a fantasy world with
strange and wonderful creatures can be
like and that there's more to world
building in a fantasy setting than just
my job here is done
[Music]
i didn't [ __ ] my cat i didn't come on my
cat i didn't put my dick anywhere near
my cat i've never done anything weird
with my cats i promised myself i wasn't
going to make apology videos after last
year's thing so i'm just trying to be as
short and honest with this as possible
[Music]
on the latest episode of now that's what
i call culture nekopara has finally
gotten a full anime adaptation if you
want to see cute cat girls doing cute
things because i mean who doesn't love
watching cats if you've never heard of
nekopara before it's based on the visual
novel that has a bit of a
infamous background so some alarm bells
might be ringing when you see some of
the youngest felines being like nine
months old
or are they
see those of us with a high enough iq
know that these are actually cat years i
mean this is just the reptalia argument
all over again so to prove the doubters
once and for all i have conducted a
thorough investigation to show the legal
and moral ramifications of such cat
girls exact conversion numbers do vary
from sorcerosaurus but through my
research we can still get a rough idea
of the equivalent and more important
human age and so through pure science
and math we can conclude that her age is
actually something closer to
oh
oh no
i'm gonna be honest though despite the
questionable background this was
actually pretty tame fan service wise
yeah i know but aside from a few scenes
it's mostly just wholesome fun
especially compared to some of the other
stuff we've been seeing if this is
really the worst anime has to offer
right now maybe anime has started the
new decade by turning over a new leap
turning over a new league
[Music]
i can't see big anime titties anymore
because most of them are childless
single men who masturbate to anime at
first you had my curiosity
but now you have my erection
they did it
the matlabs
they actually did it all right i'm
getting ahead of myself how can i
describe this show imagine review bra
had a squad but instead of going around
reviewing different fast food joints
they went around sleeping with a bunch
of monster girl prostitutes and
reviewing the smash that's it
that's the show
my disappointment
is non-existent
and my day is made you know for real
it's actually pretty damn funny if
you're fine with the concept being what
it is but the real thing i want to
appreciate is the new achievements this
show has made as we know anime has
recently been pushing the boundary with
what you can get away with but this show
has taken it so far by essentially just
showing full-on sex scenes funimation
actually dropped it because it fell
outside of their company standards and
the japanese network tokyo mx has
full-on cancelled the television
broadcast on their channel here in japan
that's right
we've finally done it
we can no longer tell the difference
between anime and hentai
remember this well because this is a
moment that will go down in anime
history and i just want to take a moment
to appreciate this momentous occasion as
we can finally witness the evolution of
anime and the birth of a new genre as we
enter
this new decade
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
thank you so much
i'm so proud of you all
[Applause]
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you very much for daddy book
walker for sponsoring me again today you
can click the link below to find all the
source material they have for all the
airing shows this season and with that
said thank you very much too we bologist
ricky zob mondo bdd in your life thomas
piertato walto lauken and everyone else
my patreon for helping to support me for
this month also just a quick
announcement but this summer i will be
attending smash con in sydney australia
on the 18th and 19th of july i think
it's gonna be my very first time in
australia so i'm pretty excited so um
yeah hope to see any of you aussies out
there anyway that's it from me no
further updates today i've been giggup
and i will see you all next time